fox news capturing shocking video of
suspected cartel members firing
automatic weapons across the border into
the u.s meanwhile president biden's
so-called borders are kamala harris
skipping the high-level security talks
with mexican officials to make a trip to
the new jersey bakery to look at
cupcakes and that delicious coconut cake
right thanks to differ on the coconut
cake
senator marshall blackburn joins us live
though from mission texas where she's
getting a first-hand look at the crisis
so as the vice president
might solve the debate between rachel
and i but over coconut cakes you are
actually taking a look a first-hand look
at the issue
at hand senator blackburn what we see in
that video is pretty shocking that seems
to be a growing chaotic situation in
texas and mexico
it is indeed a growing chaotic situation
will and the border patrol and all these
are down here in operation lone star had
invited me to come down
spend a day
work with them see firsthand number one
issue with tennesseans is having a
secure southern border and you were
showing the footage of the fire what is
so interesting the cartel
and there are three cartels that are
working down here they have great
respect for the rule of law
the border patrol wants to do their job
the biden administration will not let
them
the cartels are afraid of the texas
national guard and texas law enforcement
so they're getting really bold because
they know biden is weak
they know they can start to create more
chaos here on the border as they try to
force this humanitarian crisis here at
our southern border
this is something that you know these
cartels are taking such advantage and
are causing such harm to these families
that are trying to come into the u.s
illegally it is a very sad situation it
is a dangerous situation and as i heard
yesterday from ranchers property owners
the cbp the texas law enforcement
this is a national security a
humanitarian and a health care issue it
absolutely is and i'll tell you you know
univision um the spanish language
television throughout this since biden
has been elected has been interviewing
cartel members you know who are doing
the smuggling and they'll they will
directly say in spanish we're doing this
because the laws have changed biden says
we can do this we're going to take
advantage of this situation um and
you're right it is so dangerous but
what's fascinating to me senator is that
we were supposedly getting kamala harris
who as you saw is at the bakery instead
of the border
she was supposed to be addressing the
root causes ever since these policies
have happened ever since she's become
borders are
the cartels are stronger than ever and
they're creating
more chaos more instability in mexico
and central america because they're
richer than ever
that is right they're making millions of
dollars
i had a rancher yesterday look at me and
he said where's kamala i just want to
know where she is she was supposed to to
solve this problem the ranchers and
farmers are having to spend thousands
tens of thousands of dollars to protect
their property you have these
families that are coming from 150
different countries around the world and
they are spending tens of thousands of
dollars to get across this border
because the cartel is telling them oh
you know we'll smuggle you in and they
are endangering these children some of
these children are coming by themselves
rachel it is heartbreaking they have
found children who have died they have
found children who are left in the
middle of nowhere as young as five six
seven years old by these cartels the
cartels are not afraid of this
administration and as you said
right now they are more brazen they're
bolder they're
endangering these lives they know that
the u.s taxpayer dollar is going to help
carry
that person from the water's edge to
wherever it is they are going in the
united states
and as you said all the time the cartel
gets richer they are making millions of
dollars every week this needs to stop
you're right senator
we're grateful for your time
unfortunately we're out of time but
you're you're down there getting the
real story while the vice president is
not i know we also know you're on top of
the story of the attorney general who's
going after parents when it turns out
his daughter uh is actually working with
groups that are pushing crt but we're
out of time we know you're working on
multiple things at one time seems the
administration not quite capable of that
and we hope to have you back to talk
about that thank you senator blackburn
appreciate it